Imperial Grand Admiral, Chiss warrior,
bluest man in the galaxy — Thrawn is
known as many things. Here's the
question, though: who is he really?
Although Thrawn was the main antagonist of
Star Wars Rebels for two of its four seasons,
precious little was revealed in the show
about his origins. However, the Star Wars:
Thrawn novels plug the gap nicely, revealing
much about Thrawn's people, the Chiss.
The Chiss are a race living in the Unknown
Regions, an area made remote by cosmic
obstacles such as black holes, keeping them
largely hidden from outsiders. However,
this isolation acts as a double-edged sword, as
the people of the Unknown Regions lack access
to technologies that might have allowed them to
traverse the dangers of their region of space.
Fortunately for the Chiss, some of their young
hold a strong connection to the Force, giving
them the ability to chart safe courses through
the Unknown Regions. However, the Chiss rarely,
if ever, venture out of their home area. This is
because they are governed by the ruling body known
as the Chiss Ascendancy, which enacts policies
of secrecy to prevent the species' discovery.
Though Thrawn's birth name was Kivu'raw'nuru, his
name is changed to "Mitth'raw'nuruodo" as a sign
of respect during his successful military
career. The name ‘Thrawn’ comes from this;
a short-hand name that combines his
new family name with his given name.
The Chiss were not alone in the Unknown Regions,
however. Their biggest threat is
an alien race called the Grysk.
Known for their warlike nature and mind
control abilities, the Grysk are ruled
by a Hegemony very similar to the Galactic
Empire in makeup, with the biggest similarity
between the two governments being a desire
to expand their influence at any cost. In
studying the Grysk and their tactics, Thrawn
inadvertently made himself an invaluable asset
for Palpatine's Empire. But the battle against
the Grysk wasn't without its own complications.
While the Empire ruled the galaxy for
a relatively brief period of time,
the Grysk were established early enough that
they were able to monitor the Clone Wars,
indicating their ambitions had been planned out
for some time. But while the Grysk certainly had
designs to expand their empire, they had to
go through the Chiss to realize their goals.
The Chiss Ascendancy realized this and sought
allies to fight the Grysk — a task
eventually given to Captain Thrawn.
Thrawn's loyalty to the Chiss stands
above all else. So how and why did
he come to serve the Empire? The "why" is
surprisingly simple: the Chiss Ascendancy
needed to determine whether the Empire
could help them defeat the Grysk Hegemony,
so they ordered Thrawn to join the Imperial
military. They wanted him to either convince
the Empire to stand with the Chiss against
the Grysk, or manipulate events such that
the Grysk would attack the Empire first,
giving the Chiss more time to prepare.
The "how" is a bit more complicated. To help
convince the Empire he has nowhere else to go,
Thrawn fakes his exile from the Chiss.
Then he chooses a world he knows the Empire
will eventually explore — and waits.
Once the Empire comes to the planet,
he slowly and methodically
picks off their scouting party,
eventually forcing their retreat. Thrawn takes
this opportunity to sneak aboard an Imperial
ship and allow himself to be captured.
Once on board, he tells his "story" to
the ranking officers. Impressed with his tactical
skills, they bring him before Emperor Palpatine.
[evil laughter]
Thrawn gains favor with the Emperor on the
basis of his history with Anakin Skywalker,
whom he had met during the Clone Wars.
Although Thrawn doesn't receive any guarantees,
Palpatine does agree to consider helping the
Chiss if Thrawn serves the Empire faithfully.
Although Thrawn ultimately swears allegiance
to the Empire and Palpatine, the effort he
makes to gain the Emperor's trust proves that
his loyalty to the Chiss remained undimmed.
While Thrawn holds up his end of the deal to serve
the Empire faithfully, his methods put him at odds
with some high-ranking Imperial officials. In
order to protect himself from the threat of a
court-martial, he attends several parties held by
powerful members of the Empire. At one such party,
Thrawn comes into contact with Arihnda Pryce, an
ambitious government employee. Although nothing
significant occurred in their first meeting, their
connection would prove to be mutually beneficial.
When Pryce is blackmailed by a rival, Thrawn
gives her valuable advice to turn the tables. This
advice allows her to thwart her blackmailer
and become governor of the Lothal Sector.
Some time later, Pryce and Thrawn work together
on a military campaign to crush a small group
of rebels on the planet Batonn. Pryce is
responsible for a large number of civilian
casualties during the uprising, which outrages
Thrawn. He initially plans on reporting Pryce's
misdeeds to the Imperial Security Bureau, but
is convinced otherwise when Pryce offers to
get Thrawn promoted to Grand Admiral —
a ranking Thrawn understandably covets,
as it would allow him to better proceed with
his primary mission for the Chiss. However,
Pryce's offer comes with a catch: she will
only secure his promotion if Thrawn brought
his fleet to the Lothal system to deal with
the rebel cell known as Phoenix Squadron.
Thrawn begins his war against Phoenix
Squadron almost immediately after receiving
his promotion to Grand Admiral. Although
he finds an opportunity to destroy the
rebel ship Ghost during a raid at Recklam
station, Thrawn allows the ship to go free
in order to reel in a much larger prize: the
location of Phoenix Squadron's hidden base.
In order to better understand how the rebels
operated, Thrawn spends much of his time
analyzing their past and their strategies.
Thrawn's almost religious study of all things
Phoenix Squadron pays big dividends when he
recognizes some distinctive artwork on the
helmet of a supposed "bounty hunter" captured
by Imperial Agent Kallus. After deducing the
bounty hunter is in fact Ezra Bridger, Thrawn
realizes Kallus was a double agent. He allows
him to continue operating as one until he
makes his next transmission. Thrawn then
tracks the transmission to the planet of
Atollon and launches an all-out assault,
defeating and scattering the rebels. His
efforts to capture them are thwarted, however,
by a creature known as the Bendu. After being shot
down, Thrawn's defeat is foretold by the Bendu.
"I see your defeat, like many arms
surrounding you in a cold embrace."
Although Thrawn is victorious over
Phoenix Squadron in the short term,
the Bendu's words eventually
come back to haunt him.
After defeating the rebels on Atollon,
Thrawn is ordered by Palpatine to accompany
Darth Vader to investigate a disturbance in
the force on Batuu — the same planet on which
Thrawn and Skywalker had first met. The two
locate and capture a band of mysterious
aliens, who turn out to be Grysk agents.
Thrawn and Vader lead an assault on the
Grysk base, and, after securing victory,
locate the source of the disturbance Palpatine
had felt: Force-sensitive Chiss children,
whom the Grysk had captured in order to make
them serve as navigators. Although Vader wants
the children eliminated, Thrawn assures him that
the Force-sensitive Chiss would pose no threat,
since their connection to the Force
grows weaker when they reach adulthood.
After rooting out the remaining Grysk and
rescuing more Chiss children, Thrawn returns
them to the Ascendancy; however, he also learns
that the Chiss are heading toward a civil war,
with the Grysk backing one of the Chiss factions.
Thrawn then reasons that, since the Grysk were
attempting to capture navigators, it was likely
that they were preparing to eliminate the Chiss
so they could wage war on the Empire. While Thrawn
continues to serve the Empire in the aftermath of
this incident, these latest discoveries only
harden Thrawn's dedication to the Chiss cause.
In order to curry favor with Palpatine and
convince him to help the Chiss against the Grysk,
Thrawn decides to develop a weapon that could
ensure the Empire's stability for years to
come. He chooses to improve the standard
TIE fighter by giving it more firepower,
a hyperdrive, and a deflector shield.
The Rebel Alliance sees this new TIE fighter,
dubbed the TIE Defender, as a grave threat, since
none of their X-wing craft have the firepower to
deal with its enhanced capabilities. As a result,
the rebels authorize a raid on Lothal, where
the nuts and bolts of the project are located.
The attack is an abject failure, however, with
nearly every rebel pilot killed and their leader,
Hera Syndulla, captured. With his factory safe,
Thrawn is informed of a new threat to his TIE
Defender project: Project Stardust,
otherwise known as the Death Star.
"If construction of the Defender is to continue,
you must make your case directly
to the Emperor himself."
Concerned about the Empire's dedication
to this hugely expensive project,
Thrawn decides to meet with Palpatine
personally on Coruscant. Unfortunately,
Thrawn's journey to meet with Palpatine proves to
be the end of his project, as Governor Pryce blows
up all of the fuel for the TIE Defenders in a
successful attempt to kill the Jedi Kanan Jarrus.
The end of the TIE Defender project
holds major implications for the galaxy,
as it spurs Palpatine to throw his
support behind Project Stardust. It
is also a massive blow for Thrawn, as his avenue
of gaining favor with the Emperor is closed off.
Following the failure of the TIE Defender
project, Thrawn is ordered by the Emperor
to crush the rebellion on Lothal and capture the
young Jedi Ezra Bridger. Thrawn, eager to regain
favor with the Emperor to help save his people,
brings the might of the Seventh Fleet to bear,
threatening to blow up the capital city unless
the Jedi surrenders. After ensuring Ezra is in
the hands of the Emperor, Thrawn returns to
the bridge of his capital ship, the Chimaera,
and orders the fleet to bombard the planet.
The shelling of the capital does nothing,
however, as the rebels on the ground manage
to raise a planetary defense shield in time.
Although Thrawn sends his bodyguard,
Rukh, to shut down the planetary shield,
the rebels manage to fight off the Imperial
forces and ensure the shield's functionality.
Upon hearing of Rukh's death, Ezra enters the
bridge and demands Thrawn's surrender. Although
Thrawn was still planning on continuing the
fight, he is forestalled by the arrival of
purrgil — large space whales that are capable of
lightspeed. The purrgil completely decimate the
entirety of Thrawn's fleet, with one smashing
into the bridge of the Chimaera and wrapping
its tendrils around Thrawn, fulfilling the Bendu's
vision of the Grand Admiral's defeat. The purrgil
then jump to lightspeed, flinging both Ezra
and Thrawn to an unknown destination in space
and completely destroying any hope Thrawn
had of using the Empire to save his people.
"Um… was that the plan?"
In 1991, author Timothy Zahn wrote Heir to the
Empire. This novel, which was later adapted into
a comic series, chronicled the adventures
of Luke Skywalker, Leia Organa, Han Solo,
and their merry band of Rebels following the
events of Return of the Jedi. Set approximately
five years later, Grand Admiral Thrawn is
introduced as the next in line to restart
the Galactic Empire and crush the New Republic.
The story continues with the novels Dark Force
Rising and The Last Command, in which Thrawn's
plans are thwarted by Luke and his allies.
A few years later, the author wrote two more
novels to follow up his trilogy; this is known
as the Hand of Thrawn duology — and that was
only the beginning. The Grand Admiral would
return to play the role of recurring antagonist
throughout the Extended Universe. For decades,
the original Thrawn trilogy served as the
launching point for the greater Star Wars
Expanded Universe, but, when Disney purchased
Lucasfilm in 2012, everything changed. Thrawn,
like many other characters and stories, was
written out of continuity by the House of Mouse,
with Zahn's acclaimed trilogy being
rebranded under the "Legends" banner.
When Thrawn was eventually re-introduced into
the continuity, Lucasfilm made a few significant
changes to the character. For starters, unlike
in the Heir to the Empire storyline, the Disney
versions of Thrawn and Luke never encounter one
another. Instead, Ahsoka Tano and Ezra Bridger
serve as Thrawn's main adversaries, with Luke off
elsewhere re-establishing the fallen Jedi Order.
Selling over 15 million copies, Zahn's trilogy
was so successful that his work on Heir to the
Empire is credited by some with saving the Star
Wars franchise at a time when new adventures
were scarce. Following the original theatrical
release of Return of the Jedi and a few other
'80s projects that we really don't need to
talk about, Star Wars content had stalled
by the early '90s. George Lucas had yet to
develop the prequel trilogy, so Zahn's work
single-handedly carried the franchise, opening
the door for more Expanded Universe stories.
Though Lucas didn't consider them canon, he
nevertheless took plot beats, characters,
and locations from the EU and added
them to his new films. No doubt,
Thrawn's popularity among Star Wars fans
was a reason why Zahn's trilogy was so
successful. For many years, the Heir to
the Empire trilogy was the closest thing
to a direct "Star Wars" sequel trilogy
that fans seemed likely to witness,
as Lucas largely moved on from the franchise
from the mid-'80s to the turn of the century.
Thrawn's reappearances in various novels,
games, and comics were quite welcome among
fans before Disney swooped in and
took over. It also explains why the
character survived the House of Mouse's
purge of the greater Extended Universe;
he was too important to fans to be erased
entirely. Perhaps understandably, some fans
still hold out hope that other characters
from this era could one day return as well.
"No one's ever really gone."
Grand Admiral Thrawn had the pleasure of
meeting both Anakin Skywalker and Darth
Vader during very different phases of the
former Jedi's life. The 2018 novel Thrawn:
Alliances revolves around the brief partnership
between the Sith Lord and the warlord as they work
together to investigate the Force disturbance
on Batuu. But Alliances doesn't just cover
this partnership between Thrawn and Vader
— it also flashes back to the Clone Wars,
when Thrawn and the young Skywalker
worked together to save Padmé Amidala.
During this time, Thrawn deduces that Anakin is a
Jedi. Although Anakin believes his role as a Jedi
was obvious, given the color of his lightsaber,
Thrawn explains his hesitation. He tells Anakin:
"Our myths of the Republic speak of
two groups of beings with such powers:
the Jedi, and the Sith. But the Sith are
reputed to be clever and capable warriors."
As it turns out, Anakin's numerous mistakes in
combat allowed Thrawn to correctly identify him
as a Jedi. Years later, Emperor Palpatine
tells Thrawn of Skywalker's death following
the Clone Wars. Despite this lie, the Chiss
double agent quickly deduces that Lord Vader
and the former General Skywalker are one and
the same. As one of the only people in the
galaxy to uncover this safeguarded information,
Thrawn keeps it to himself. Smart move, Thrawn.
Since the Chiss are so far removed from the
known galaxy, they have little to no knowledge
of society in the Republic. Nevertheless, the
Force still extends into the Unknown Regions,
even if the people who reside there don't
actually know what it is. For the Chiss people,
Force-sensitive children may not have
the same giftings as other races do,
but they still retain a premonition
ability which they call "Third Sight."
Because of their ability to peer into
the future, children with "Third Sight"
are conscripted to become space-faring
navigators, since the Chiss don't use
traditional technological navigation.
Thrawn's older sister Kivu'rik'ardok,
otherwise known as Vurika, was one
of these Force-sensitive children,
and was taken when Thrawn was just a boy. As an
adult, like many Chiss children with Third Sight,
Vurika lost her precognitive abilities and instead
worked as an instructor for future navigators.
Despite being siblings, when confronted with the
chance to finally meet her long-lost brother,
Vurika, now known as Borika, after her marriage,
weeps, believing that there is no point since her
memories of Thrawn have long faded. Tragically,
despite having once believed that one day he
might use his resources to find her, Thrawn never
reunites with his sister. Eventually, he comes
to respect her wishes for anonymity and moves on.
The events of the Star Wars Rebels finale,
in which Ezra Bridger and Thrawn are thrown
into the unknown, are set in the same
year as the original Star Wars film.
"I find your lack of faith disturbing."
In that movie, the Empire loses Grand Moff
Tarkin and the first Death Star at the hands
of Luke Skywalker and the Rebel Alliance. After
these two enormous defeats, the Emperor tasks
Darth Vader with personally overseeing the
destruction of the rebels. In Star Wars #8,
which is set after Vader's showdown with Luke on
Cloud City, Palpatine claims that Thrawn or Tarkin
would have been perfect for this job and laments
that both are gone. Though the task delays the
Sith Lord's search for his long-lost son, Vader
deems it necessary for the health of the Empire.
In Thrawn's absence, Darth Vader
continues to hunt down the rebels.
During the so-called "War of the Bounty
Hunters," he comes close to capturing Han
Solo and a number of his allies but ultimately
fails. Had Thrawn still been around, however,
these events might not have gone as well for Luke
and his friends, and it's entirely possible that
Luke may have been captured prior to his
surrender in Return of the Jedi. Likewise,
Vader's position overseeing construction of the
second Death Star may have been held by someone
else had Thrawn or Tarkin survived, meaning his
turn back to the light may never have occurred.
Although Thrawn is often seen as a ruthless
leader, willing to do whatever it takes
for the sake of his ambitions, this
couldn't be further from the truth.
From his youth into his Imperial career, Thrawn
always believes that every life holds some sort
of value. Though he has no problem eliminating
his enemies, he sees the deaths of innocent
civilians as senseless and unnecessary. In the
novel Thrawn Ascendancy: Greater Good, he says:
"All lives are important, and I resist the thought
of standing by and watching two
hundred possibly needless deaths."
This was especially true of Thrawn
when he served in the Chiss military,
but it generally carries over to
his time with the Empire as well.
Generally speaking, Thrawn also shows deep
respect for his enemies, but this only goes
so far. In Star Wars Rebels, Thrawn unleashes
his full fury on the Lothal system near the
end of his time there. After his increasingly
futile attempts to put the insurgency down,
he fires on the people of Capital City until
Ezra Bridger surrenders himself to the Empire.
It's worth noting that these actions come about
due to intense pressure from Emperor Palpatine,
who hopes to turn Ezra to the Dark Side
— but Thrawn is certainly still the man
in charge during the bombardment. Had
Thrawn been given more time, however,
he may have come up with an alternative solution
that didn't threaten the lives of those below.
An interesting shade to the Thrawn
character is the Grand Admiral's love,
or at least appreciation, of traditional
art and music. Believing the arts to
be a window into the history and
culture of different people groups,
Thrawn sees it as a valuable tool to be used
to better understand his allies and opponents.
"My apologies, Captain Slavin. I forgot that
not everyone is able to appreciate art as I do."
In the Zahn novel Thrawn Ascendancy: Lesser Evil,
a younger Thrawn is shown analyzing hundreds of
thousands of different pieces of artwork that
belong to his adoptive family, many of which
were created by anonymous artists. He even manages
to connect a series of seemingly unrelated works
together based solely on style and technique,
eventually discovering the artist's identity.
Likewise, in Rebels, Thrawn is shown to have
amassed an impressive collection of artwork that
all point to the crew of the Ghost, which includes
Ezra Bridger, Sabine Wren, and Hera Syndulla. In
his time studying their work, he comes to
better understand his enemies and uses this
knowledge of their goals and ideals to overpower
them. Across his various media appearances, this
appreciation for the arts has remained a strong,
consistent character trait for the Chiss warlord.
Though Thrawn isn't much of an artist himself,
his knowledge and understanding of technique
and structure have proven invaluable to his
military campaign. And it's very possible
that we'll see more of the Grand Admiral's
cultural side in future Star Wars projects.
Though there are any number of military leaders
who could have been the basis for Grand Admiral
Thrawn, Zahn revealed the exact source of his
inspiration in a letter written in 2002. He wrote:
"Thrawn isn't based on any one
historical person in particular,
but is more of a composite of the best and
brightest military geniuses that have ever lived."
On Zahn's list: Hannibal, Alexander the Great,
Robert E. Lee, and Erwin Rommel. Zahn continued to
explain Thrawn's characterization by emphasizing
that he, unlike many real-life military leaders,
genuinely cares about those under his command.
The lives of his officers matter to him, and
he has no desire to see any of them gunned down
for no reason. Since Thrawn was supposed to be
a different sort of villain than Darth Vader, who
ruled his underlings by fear, he was made into "a
tactical genius," a man who would be so respected
by his men that they would "follow him anywhere."
But Zahn wasn't only inspired by the historical
leaders of old to create Thrawn; he was also
inspired by popular fictional characters —
including a few who wouldn't have been all
that fond of the Grand Admiral's allegiances.
For example, Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's famous
detective Sherlock Holmes was a clear template
for Thrawn's ability to piece together a mystery.
"Elementary, my dear Watson. Purely elementary."
Of course, although Holmes uses his
exceptional mind to help others,
Thrawn uses it to advance the goals of the Empire…
which is a little less noble, to say the least.
Despite being the beloved antagonist of
the most well-received Star Wars novels,
the editors at Marvel Comics reportedly
had no initial interest in including the
infamous Grand Admiral in their ongoing
Star Wars titles. According to former
Marvel assistant editor Heather Antos, who
took to Twitter to show her support for
Thrawn's re-introduction into the franchise, a
"very important higher up" at Marvel told her:
"The blue guy? No one cares about him."
Of course, it was only a few years later
that Thrawn would get his own comic series
in support of his debut on Rebels. Clearly,
someone had a change of heart. And ever since
his successful return, Thrawn has become a
recurring character throughout the greater
Star Wars universe. Be it the different Marvel
comic books, various Thrawn-themed novels,
or his presence in the live-action shows,
it's clear that Thrawn is here to stay.
And of course, with the announcement
of Dave Filoni's upcoming movie,
which is set to round off the stories begun by The
Mandalorian, The Book of Boba Fett, and Ahsoka,
there's also a lot to look forward to as Thrawn
expands his grasp over the Star Wars franchise.
In addition to the Thrawn trilogy that
Timothy Zahn penned in the early '90s,
the author found the chance to tackle the
character on a number of occasions afterward.
Though Zahn wrote various sequel stories featuring
Thrawn that took place after The Last Command,
he also took on a number of novels set
in the Disney continuity. The first of
the new Thrawn trilogy was Star Wars:
Thrawn, which was followed up by Thrawn:
Alliances and Thrawn: Treason. These projects
allowed the character's creator to reintroduce
him to Star Wars as the protagonist of
his own story. And it didn't end there.
Though Zahn had reinvented Thrawn, helping
transition him from "Legends" into canon, he had
more stories to tell concerning the Grand Admiral.
In 2020, another Thrawn-based novel — titled
Thrawn Ascendancy: Chaos Rising — was published by
Zahn, this one exploring the character's history
with his people, the Chiss, and their rivalry with
the Grysk. Known as the Thrawn Ascendancy trilogy,
Zahn continued Thrawn's pre-Clone Wars story with
Greater Good in 2021 and Lesser Evil later that
year, rounding out his overhaul of the character's
past and forever changing the way fans saw the
Chiss legend. Knowing that Zahn is involved
in future Thrawn stories should give Star Wars
loyalists hope that, however the Grand Admiral
is adapted next, his creator won't be far behind.